what's the gradient at that point
because there are no two points to
compare by definition so here's what
they both do yes an Imagi so we can
picture a tangent along here in fact
that's where our language receives its
first cultural now it's hard to do the
maths with this thing because you just
got that one point ah but if I can get
towards this tangent and think of it in
terms of something else that I can
calculate something which does have two
points then I can work with this for
example if I put in a whole bunch of
parallel lines here okay all of these
guys these 1 2 3 4 that I've just drawn
what they call they intersect the circle
twice I think they're called cygnets
these guys right these guys do have two
points so I'm just going to think of the
circle because that's where your secret
in tangent language comes from and then
we'll come over to a graph in a second
can you see the length of the cord
that's cut off by this secant right the
length of this coin as I get closer and
closer to becoming a tangent as I move
this way right the lake of that cord is
getting smaller your green right in fact
eventually once you get to the tangent
the lake of that cord the length of that
cord is 0 is it not it's it's not
actually a cord it's just a single point
that's why it's actually Europe right
so what Newton wanted to do was take
this problem apart by thing here as one
of these prongs he thought what if what
if I could I can understand the behavior
of this secant what if I could have
imagined it as it approaches a chord of
length 0 if it approaches a chord of
length of 0 so both of these guys both
of these guys said I need some language
I need some language to talk about
things that approach something which you
know I can't actually get to but I can
still do the calculations on it so they
said let's talk about limits they
introduced this notation something's
getting closer and closer and closer
until you actually there right
you make conclusions also offer things
that you know so you can draw something
make that something you don't know okay
so now here's where the rubber hits the
road draw for me a new one
you said axes let's just go first
quadrant it's all you need drop me a
curve drop me okay and let's call this
some function of X some function of X
now if what I'm after is the gradient of
a tangent gradient of tangent okay what
I'm going to start thinking about is the
gradient of a secant and think about
what happens to that as it gets closer
and closer to becoming a tangent right
so in order to get a second that's not
hard you just pick any two points you
like like here and here okay and can you
sing like if the actual point I'm after
is like somewhere in the middle here
okay
if you were to draw that tangent it's
actually not that far off in terms of
its gradient compared to this secret
right like I'm in the right ballpark
yeah so I've got these two points got
these two points let's get some values
on this alright if I imagine this is
some x-coordinate who cares what it is
I'll just call it X I want it to be
anywhere that I like or they like input
some value there okay and what I'll do
is I'll think about going from that
point and going a bit further right
going like a distance of say they call
it H okay you can think that H is kind
of like for height but it's not that's
not the best description because it's
further anyway
H is the convention there are other
conventions as well sometimes you'll see
it called Delta X we'll talk about why
in a second now I hit that little
distance there it's just a small
distance is H then what's the coordinate
of this point over here or I should say
the exponent X percentage right
it's just that Plus that that gets you
over there okay
so now if I want to work out the
gradient of this secant here right the
Green in the secret I've got x
coordinates I'm going to need Y
coordinates wanna come
yeah and she okay now I don't know what
this function is it could be anything
it's f of X right so if this x
coordinate is X just X right what am I
going to be up here f of X good so for
example if this were if this were x
squared right y equals x squared then
that would be X and this would be x
squared right
this is X plus h so my corresponding Y
value over here will be f of X plus h
whatever F happens to be okay
so now what am I got here what have I
got I have got what I working out is the
gradient of the secret the greening of
this guy here okay and it's literally
just right everyone it's just lies over
one okay so it's my rise okay it's the
distance between these two points these
two Y values is it not okay what is that
distance I think that's good this take
away this yeah that's all that's all
that vertical distances okay
so rise I've got that
okay now run is the horizontal distance
that I'm going there corresponds to that
which of course I've defined as just H
it's just H so if I have some value of x
whatever you like okay and I have some
function you define it to me whatever
you like okay this will give me the gray
or a secant that's anywhere you want
okay but I don't want a secant really
what I really want is that a single
point where this distance in here I
don't want it to be this big gaping gap
in here okay I wanted to close in I
wanted to come together just like these
guys are coming together right so what I
want is this guy here H I wanted to get
very very very small does that make
sense
now I already have language for this
right when it becomes zero I'm going to
get not a secret not a secret but a
tangent degree with that right that's
what I want what I want is for H to be
zero and H can't really be zero because
look I have to divide by H I can't
really be zero but I can think about
what happens as I get closer to zero I
just have to say tell me what the limit
is right tell me what the limit is just
like we looked at before if I gave you a
trivial example
okay we looked at on we looked at
evaluating limits like that okay now
that function there that I've put over
here it's got a hole at five doesn't
it's like that you can't equal five
because it's on the denominator so x
equals 5 is not going to work okay but
all I need to do is I just have to say
well that top thing what can you do that
topic I can factorize it it's the
difference of squares so it's going to
be X plus 5 X minus 5 and because of
that a denominator goes no problem
okay so at that point I could say oh
that thing that thing that approaches 5
and I can actually put in 5 so the
course is just going to be 10 right so
even though this original thing
I can't put five in I can see what
happens as it approaches five it's going
to go there okay from above and below
you can go ahead and try it out so here
I can't put in zero but I can think
about what happens as I get ever closer
to it okay so this thing here this guy
is a big deal okay
this was likenesses and Newton's big
watershed moment they're like I can't I
can't work out by just putting in 0
right at least into this which is what
it is my definition rise over run but I
can still do maths with it I can still
do maths with it even if I can't
actually put 0 in this is what we call
the first principles of calculus the
first principle what are we actually
working out we're working out the
gradient of the tangent okay but this
started to get a bit awkward in terms of
like talking about all this stuff so
they introduced new language and they
introduced a new notation okay so the
new language they introduces they call
this thing right like I could get it at
a particular point but I get a
particular point but I could get it at
any point I like right and it's going to
change all the way so run in this thing
which has a gradient okay this thing
over here is going to be a function
changes right so it's actually called
their gradient function because the
gradient is going to take on different
values depending on where you look
depending on what value of x you look at
okay now in the same way he said look
this rise over run business rise over
run it's not working because there's not
really a run it's not really a roam okay
so they said look this is just the
change in Y divided by the change in X
that's that's all it's really happy
right so you guys know the symbol in
science right for changes in Delta now
use it
and they say the change in Y that's rise
right and you compare you gets ratio
with its change in X that's the run
except one is an inadequate work because
there's not really any run happening
here right so dy change in y over DX
change in X it means rise over run but
in that case where the rise of run are
both tending towards 0 because looking
at this infinitesimally small squat the
rise is going to be zero the ones game
is here but you can still see how about